das ist gerade noch mal gut gegangen im
hessischen bad hersfeld hat ein
radfahrer in der nacht zu mittwoch einen
dachstuhlbrand bemerkt und somit das
leben eine familie gerettet fahrrad hier
vorbeigefahren und habe gerochen dass
irgendwo was brennen müsste was brennen
könnte und habe mich dann mein fahrrad
noch mal um getreten habe gesehen dass
aus dem dachstuhl rauch aufkam und habe
dann sofort die leitstelle alarmiert und
habe die leute aus dem schlaf geklingelt
die haben oben in dem zimmer wo es
ausgebrochen ist im schlaf gelegen ich
bin dann noch mal hoch da waren so
halogen spots in der decke drin wie ich
es gemacht habe und habe da oben mit 24
schon mal den ersten brand so ein
bisschen niedergedrückt und habe damit
den weg für die feuerwehr vernünftig
freigemacht
rettungskräfte konnten das feuer unter
kontrolle bringen möglicherweise wurde
das durch einen technischen defekt
ausgelöst
zwei passiert so dass die anwohner
wirklichen tischler fahren und wenn die
nicht durch rauchmelder oder ähnliches
geweckt worden wären wäre wahrscheinlich
der ganze dachstuhl oben ausgebrochen
der junge mann den rauch gesehen hat ist
auch selber aktiver feuerwehrmann hier
im nachbau und hat da wirklich richtig
gut gehandelt
der schaden beläuft sich immerhin auf
50.000 euro
doch zum glück wurde niemand verletzt
unser held des tages ist mir jetzt auch
zugeschaltet guten morgen herr wetzel
sagen sie mit etwas abstand wie erleben
sie jetzt noch einmal diese ganze
geschichte für sich
die ganze geschichte erlebe ich jetzt
mit ein bisschen abstand
ja sehr sehr distanziert es ist wahnsinn
was hätte passieren können wenn ich
nicht da gewesen wäre
was war denn der gefährlichste moment
dieser rettung sowohl für sie als auch
für die familie die sie gerettet haben
der gefährlichste moment war im
endeffekt der moment wo ich die familie
aus dem haus geholt haben und haben
angefangen selber den löschangriff
vorzunehmen um der feuerwehr zeit zu
verschaffen damit die die mögliche zeit
haben um die drehleiter aufzubauen und
von innen und außen mit löschkräften den
vernünftigen löschangriff vorzubereiten
dadurch dass ich dann halt die
feuerlöscher zur verfügung hatte hatte
ich die möglichkeit da schon mal
vorzuarbeiten
haben sie denn jetzt noch einmal kontakt
zu der familie gehabt nach dieser
rechnung
ich war gestern noch mal bei der familie
und habe noch nämlich noch mal mit ihnen
unterhalten und habe mir das alles im
nachgang noch mal in ruhe angeschaut und
habe die schäden am haus besichtigt und
habe mich mit denen noch meine ruhe
unterhalten und die sind überglücklich
die konnten das den abend überhaupt noch
nicht fassen noch nicht wahrnehmen was
da jetzt genau passiert ist jetzt
mittlerweile fängt das an dass sie
realisieren was wirklich passiert wäre
wenn ich sie nicht geweckt hatte